[Musique]
les rubalises sont à peine posé et c'est
aussi le dernier coup de pioche depuis
plusieurs semaines dans toute l'île les
agents comme jean moïse près par 54% des
sentiers de la diagonale des fous
imagine déjà les jours toit dont me fais
le mieux possible que le guen jade léa
l'aide de l'ue sur l'entier enfin mais
son mari voilà déjà un moment important
qui vient conclure en cycle de travail
même si l'action a lieu toute l'année
bien sûr on est passé sur l'ensemble du
chantier on a nettoyé bien pour que ça
se passe bien mais ya pas eu
d'investissements lourds pour permettre
le grand raid et il y aura pas d'impact
lourd après le passage et 6000 coureurs
milieux littoraux savane et forêt sèche
forêt de bois de couleurs débat les
milieux de montagne ou encore les
végétations de haute altitude
l'accès aux multiples usages dans les
milieux naturels est une question de
compromis est une question d'équilibré
pour trouver le bon tracé qui permettra
de faire une belle course qui contentera
les coureurs l'organisateur qui fera des
belles images en termes de retombées
économiques touristiques et bien entendu
de concilier avec une gestion durable du
domaine forestier donc en canalisant en
régulant les coureurs en créant les
conditions pour qu'ils puissent va la
garder de ne pas mettre leurs déchets
sur sur les sentiers donc tous à une
histoire d'équilibré et de travail tout
au long de l'année le grand raid se
prépare tout au long de l'année c'est
pour cela que ces pochettes seront
distribués à tous les coureurs une
occasion de la rappeler la fragilité des
lieux de quoi profiter en toute
responsabilité
[Musique]